[Musique]
bon bah
bonjour disent bonjour ça va ça va ça va
est ce que vous diriez vous êtes un
garçon engagé j'en sais trop rien ça
dépend des jours vise au moins je ne me
regarde pas en me disant je ne pense pas
la question de savoir si je suis engagé
je ne me regarde pas dans une glace pour
savoir si je donne l'image de quelqu'un
d'engagé c'est pas d'histoire d'image
qu'est ce que vous portez dans vos
tripes
alors pour moi c'était une évidence que
vous allez me dire évidemment je suis
engagé bien sûr je suis engagé bah on
l'est sans s'en rendre compte en fait
c'est un peu comme on fait de la prose
monsieur jourdain fait de l'engagement
sans se rendre compte en fait on est
toujours engagé depuis je me sens enfin
engagé je me sens impliqué dans dans ce
qui se passe autour de moi depuis que je
suis gamin en fait voilà donc sa nature
oui oui oui c'est bas il ya une
curiosité pour le monde qui a tourné
vous pour ce qui se passe autour de vous
et pour c'est de comprendre ce qui se
passait et aussi vous positionnez-vous
comment se positionne moi je me
positionne dans ce monde là absolument
vous m'avez amenée un objet pour qui
symbolise votre engagement à vous mais
le voir maintenant bah ouais ça vous
ennuie n'en voulait qu'on voit plus tard
on me dit non généraux de journal qu un
peu particulier parce qu'en fait il ya
des trous dedans en fait c'est un joint
qui était troué par les les balles du 7
janvier
et voilà en rangeant le journal on a
découvert des liasses de journaux qui
avait traversé par des balles et on
ouvre on les envoie en ouvrant ses
liasses c'est bien on a découvert les
morceaux de métal comme ça ça s'est il
déballe sa une mais balouet et vous
vivez avec cet objet vous arrivez à
vivre avec cet objet bajeux liens de jeu
le garde parce que parce que ça fait
partie de l'histoire du journal coup oui
maintenant et plus largement que ça ça
fait partie de notre histoire à tous non
c'est sûr et peut-être qu'il faudra le
montrer en public des fois je me dis que
ça mériterait d'être exposés pour qu'on
se rende compte de ce que c'est qu'un
journal qui physiquement subit la
violence quoi quand vous faites un
journal et puis que vous
découvrez les exemplaires trou et voilà
ça c'est du real quoi et c'est
irréversible quoi c c'est l'histoire du
journal quoi quand les frères quoi chez
vous tire dessus
est-ce qu'il change la nature de votre
engagement non il change rien du tout il
change de l'intensité de l'engagement
c'est à dire que ce sera encore plus
engagés après tant qu'il le pousse un
peu quand même
il le change dans le sens où vous avez
dû prendre une place qui était pas celle
que vous aviez avant oui ou mais ça
c'est des circonstances ces presque
secondaire politiquement ça change rien
mon engagement si ce n'est que c'est
seulement quand encore plus déterminés
j'aurais tendance à dire plus on me tape
dessus plus j'ai envie de de réagir mais
aussi donc ça va pas mal ça va pas m'a
fait lire sa maman contraire me voilà
mais on encore plus déterminés ouais si
vous voulez je vous le rend parce que
ouais je sais pas c'est un drôle de
rapport mois avec cet objet c'est très
impressionnant que vous vous à manier ça
en fait c'est pas parce que des fois je
vous dis que les gens se rendent pas
vraiment compte de ce que c'est
concrètement oisivement voilà ce que
c'est que la violence en fait c'est sous
un peu abstrait et ça l'était pour vous
avant de vivre ça peut pas on peut pas
avoir la même compréhension de ce qui
vous est arrivé vous et moi même si on
sait tous ce qui s'est passé c'est
impossible pour moi d'imaginer ce qui
vous est arrivé même si vous l'écrivez
même si vous le raconter pour vous le
dites wi fi
il ya toujours quelque chose qui sera
irracontable on peut raconter beaucoup
de choses on peut décrire au coût de
choses mais au bout d'un moment vous
vous heurter un mur sorte de plafond de
verre vous ne pouvez pas aller au delà
de certains niveaux d'explications ou de
transmission aux autres voilà mais il ya
des choses que l'on peut transformer par
exemple au pont pour qu'en dix ans sans
vouloir le dire par exemple vous vous
n'avez jamais arrêté de dessiner vous
avez dessiné à l'hôpital mauvaises mains
blessé à l'épaule
vous êtes obligés d'utiliser la main
avec laquelle vous dessinez pas il
n'arrêtait pas jamais jamais jamais vous
vous êtes dit jamais vous avez pris le
temps de vous dirai ce que j'ai envie
vraiment de continuer ou est ce que
peut-être je pourrais arrêter c'était
pas de question d'envisager une question
plus de l'interrogation sur mac mes
capacités physiques
parce que quand vous êtes à l'hôpital
vous avez vraiment au fond du trou et si
on s'épuise vite donc je me disais mais
dans quel état je serai physiquement
dans six mois dans un an mais se
remettait pas en cause la détermination
de ce que je voulais faire je dirais
même au contraire que tout ce qui nous
arrive et ne faisait que confirmer tout
ce à quoi on croyait pour lequel on se
battait toute l'équipe de charlie avant
donc sa dernière tragique sa valider
toutes nos convictions
le fait que sans même qu'on s'en
aperçoive des nouvelles formes de
tyrannie se met en place
apparaissent et essaye de s'imposer aux
autres voilà quand on essayait
d'expliquer ça au moment du procès des
caricatures les gens pensaient que
c'était uniquement un problème de
dessinateurs un des dessinateurs apple
anticléricaux voilà ils n'ont pas
compris que c'était annonciateur de
quelque chose de plus profond et qu'ils
allaient toucher tout le monde et on l'a
vu ensuite après avec la vague
d'attentats qui a touché tout le monde
il est très vieux ce point que vous
soulevez en 72 brassens est attaquée et
elle en a marre et décide d'écrire une
chanson une des très rares chansons
politiques qu'il a écrites dans cette
chanson est dit que il faut se méfier de
toutes les idéologies on écoute les
idées avec l'amant
le fameux sacrifices les sectes de tout
poil
anne offre des séquelles
et la question se pose aux victimes
novice
mourir pour des idées c'est bien beau
mais lesquels et comme tout son temps
tel ressemblante
quand il les voit venir avec leurs gros
drapeau le singe allez-y temps tourne
autour du tombeau mouron pour des idées
d'accord mais de mort lente eu d'accord
mais de mort lente
en plus c'est quoi cette photo je n'y
allais pas peut dater en fait ouais si
c'est pas aussi il n'ya pas une chanson
écrite dans dans dans la veine d'un
certain pacifisme des années 20 des
années 30 oui c'est vrai effectivement
pour un drapeau on en voyait des gens se
faire massacrer
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya ça en tête et
antimilitariste clairement mais c'est
aussi pour dire attention je pense que
c'est aussi contre des formes de
nationalisme comme ce que l'europe a pu
connaître dans les années 20 où des
années 30 mais peut-être qu'on nous on a
une autre époque c'est plus vraiment des
nationalismes
on doit dire à l'ancienne en tous les
cas même si on voit beaucoup de partis
xénophobes en europe a émergé en
grillant en pologne a encore beaucoup de
nationalismes en europe
mais c'est vrai qu'on est moi je pense
pas qu'on soit vraiment dans les années
30 non plus mais mourir pour des idées
ça oui ça oui c'est bien il faut on peut
on doit alors passer comme ça pleurait
parce que des idées kelly des
magiciennes celles auxquelles on croit
ou et mesures c'est quelque chose que
petit peut être invoqué aussi par eux
attendus par les fascistes
oui par des voies la part des tirs en
convent par les rires
donc c'est un peu trop large comme deux
finitions il ya de nouveaux dessinateurs
qui ont rejoint la rédac de charlie ils
sont engagés
j'espère s'ils sont venus vers le
journal sans qu'on les force
quand on bosse et charlie d'avoir un
grand sens de l'humour de la dérision
être journaliste est aussi avoir un sens
de l'engagement fort à les deux fautes
politisé voilà c'est plus précis que
l'engagement être politisée faut
s'intéresser à la politique
oui il faut s'intéresser à l'histoire
faut s'intéresser à la culture parce que
souvent le mot enfin la satire fait
référence à beaucoup de choses
et souvent les dessins sont mal compris
parce qu'il ya un manque de culture
politique même de culture tout court
c'est vrai que le jeu dans la satire
compterait des dessins c'est des
références c'est un peu voilà on joue
aussi avec tout un tas de choses des
références graphiques des références
historiques politiques mais si on les a
pas on ne comprend rien et pour faire
des mets ça comme ça il va déjà il faut
aussi les avoir donc un dessinateur
satirique à charlie c'est un secteur qui
est politisé rétro et courageux vos
jeunes collègues qui vous qui vous
rejoignent sais pas je devais embrasser
pour charlie quoi oui mais c'est pas le
mot courageux parce que je les trouves
comment dire
ils ont la même là même le même
enthousiasme que celui qu'on avait en 92
quand le charbo luz nous si on voulait
faire plein de trucs
voilà et c'est très bien c'est ce qu'on
allait faire mais on avait envie de
faire un journal et de se marrer de
découvrir le monde à travers ce journal
et de et de faire partager sa au lecteur
donc il ya un peu le même enthousiasme
voilà il est là intacte ben il est la
renouveler voilà à nouveau là
le temps passe est-ce que parfois vous
vous oubliez je peux oublier des détails
parce qu'on mais j'oublie pas je ne
pardonne pas mais je n'oublie pas non
plus des émotions furtive
des ambiances des atmosphères liés à ce
moment là c'est des choses je ne sais
pas si j'ai peut-être une mémoire
sensorielle aiguë mais je peux me
souvenir de l'ambiance d'un moment pas
seulement le des faits mais de
l'électricité du moment là deux et c'est
vrai que je joue le jeu c'est difficile
c'est pas possible d'oublier cette
fébrilité qu'on ressent quand on voit
quelqu'un qui arrive devant vous avec
une arme
voilà d'un seul coup tout est suspendu
le temps est suspendu et vous savez vous
savez vous avait basculé dans quelque
chose
donc ça je descends mémoire pas
seulement visuellement mais physiquement
c'est physique il mémoire physique des
choses j'ai employé le mot oublie exprès
j'ai le sentiment que vous avez peur
qu'on oublie que nous on oublie quand
vous m'avez dédicacer votre email quand
je les ai reçus y avait écrit pour ne
rien oublier pour tenter de donner au
lecteur d d d outils pour ne pas trop
oublié en tous les cas parce que c'est
sur le temps passe inévitablement comme
tous les événements politiques ou
historiques à un moment donné voilà vous
avez des jeunes aujourd'hui je discute
avec une personne qui ne savent pas trop
ce que c'est que le 11 septembre 2001
qui dit mais moi ma fille c'est parce
que c'est que le 11 septembre 2001 c'est
à dire que on a l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui les jeunes en général ne
connaissent que les événements qui l'ont
connu dans leur propre vie oui et si
c'est si ça eu lieu avant ça n'existe
pas ou alors ils semblaient faire un
effort vraiment où il faut leur mettre
sous le nez et un jour mais peut-être
que le 7 janvier comme tout ce qui s'est
passé en 2015
ça deviendra un évènement antérieur aux
existences nouvelles qui vont arriver et
ça sortira de quelque chose de concret
du coup vous avez presque plus peur de
nous que de que des terroristes plus
peur de la trahison qu'on pourrait faire
nous alors que c'est vraiment dans nos
vies à tous bien sûr que les gens qui
ont vécu cet événement
ne l'oublions pas mais eux
personnes qui vont naître dans un an ou
deux ans trois ans les seront qu'à des
journalistes sont morts en france parce
que il dessinait au parce que peut-être
ou peut-être pas c'est même pas sûr que
peut-être les gens qui naîtront dans les
générations à venir s'intéresseront à ça
c'est grave qu'il ne le sache pas si
graves qu'ils ne sachent pas ça comme
bien d'autres choses oui mais pas que ça
et voilà c'est c'est grave ne pas bien
connaître l'histoire de la société dans
lequel on émerge
oui je pense c'est encore pareil
l'engagement moi quand j'étais gamin ou
ado j'étais préoccupé de comprendre que
là où j'étais mais aussi le pas ce
qu'ils avaient avant ça vient d'où ça je
pense que pour se sentir bien il faut il
faut comment dire voir il faut savoir où
on est fous trouver sa place sa place
dans le temps dans l'espace il n'y a pas
un enfant qui s'est fait happer
certainement puisque vous l'avez fait
vous mais c'est assez peu commun de se
dire moi en tant qu'enfant je suis dans
ce monde qu'est ce qui se passait avant
oui qu'est ce qui se racontait avant
qu'à ce qu'ils ont vécu avant pas tout
le monde n'a pas cette démarche à la
serre les enfants c'était pas une
démarche c'est simplement le fait
d'écouter les adultes qui avait beaucoup
de choses à raconter qu'ils avaient vécu
des choses voilà les générations
d'adultes à cette époque là bas toutes
les scènes génération avait connu la
guerre avait connu des guerres les plus
anciens avaient connu la première guerre
mondiale
on avait voilà
autour de nous on avait des gens qui
avaient fait la guerre 14 qui est
estropiés et puis on avait d'autres qui
plus tard avait fait la guerre 39-45
aussi des choses raconté qu'elle et qui
racontait vous aviez un grand-père une
grand-mère qui racontait je me souviens
j'avais un camarade de classe elle
c'était long son père était résistant et
on habitait moulin et me raconter que
d'un moulin la ligne de démarcation et
son père traverser à la nage la ligne de
démarcation pour passer de la zone vers
la zone occupée
donc voila vous vous aviez ce genre de
témoignage et ce n'était pas des
témoignages historiques ces témoignages
de votre vie voilà c'est des gens avec
les viviers c'était donc il vient
comment ne pas s'intéresser et comment à
ce qu'est ce qui s'est passé avant c'est
dur de je vois bien que pour vous c'est
presque évident que ça va de soi et que
c'est presqu'en l'étonnement que ça ne
soit pas communément répandue mais c'est
parfois dur de penser en ce moment c'est
difficile de penser
moi je suis très admiratif par exemple
de vos éditos parce que je me dis mais
comment il fait pour avoir un avis clair
comme ça surtout c'est difficile de
penser qu est ce que je pense du voile
en tant que femme est-ce qu'il faut
l'interdire est-ce qu'il faut l'autorisé
qu'est ce qu'on fait de ces mômes qui
ont été emmenés par leurs parents en
syrie et qui ernandez quand est-ce qu'il
faut qu'ils reviennent ou pas j'en sais
rien qu'est-ce qu'on fait des
djihadistes qui ont fini leur peine de
prison c'est dur de penser c'est
qu'est-ce que comment vous aimeriez que
est ce que vous décrivez c'est la
politique
oui ces cieux dès qu'on essaye de
comprendre la vie en société la vie en
collectivité
ça devient tout de suite très compliqué
et ça sera jamais simple et pas
seulement ces problèmes là mais plein
d'autres donc si on justement pour
parler d'engagement si on passe
encourage à demain et qu'on se coltine
pas cette difficulté
d'abord que je pense qu'on sera submergé
on sera écrasée par les temps par parle
par les événements on sera balayée si on
ne veut pas être balayés bas il faut au
moins comprend cela autour de vous pour
trouver la bonne position pour ne pas se
faire justement effacés pour exister en
fait si vous comprenez pas votre
gouvernement vous vous vous n'existez
pas quoi et si vous ne trouvez pas votre
place également je dis ça parce que et
ça revient à ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure je pensais à ce film incroyable
de louis malle lacombe lucien passionnés
l'histoire de ce moment un peu perdu un
peu il veut rentrer en résistance et les
résistants lui dise non vas-y bouge et
du coup il va à la gestapo il veut
trouver une place absolument
alors il la trouve pas cher hésitant il
va les trouver chez les méchants trouver
sa place à n'importe quel prix est ce
que ça justifie tout mais moi j'ai
jamais dit qu'il laisserait sa place à
un important mais trouver sa place pour
déjà pour ne pas être pour pas se faire
écraser aussi oui et trouver sa place
aussi c'est aussi tout c'est le titre ou
à la place des autres parce que notre
place elle existe aussi avec les autres
donc c'est tenir compte des autres
donc ça vous oblige à prendre en contre
ben voilà la collectivité ce qu'on
appelle les autres et c'est peut-être ça
aussi qui vous évite de faire peut-être
des mauvais choix comme lacombe lucien
si on te prend pas suffisamment en
compte le collectif mais peut-être qu'on
s'égare
voilà quand on dit je suis charlie ça
engage à quoi pour ceux qui disent ah
oui faut leur demander
et vous vous lisez quoi quand quelqu'un
vous dit je suis charlie j'irais pas
jusqu'a dire prouve le mois mai mais on
entend ça se voit dans vos yeux
c'est tout ce que vous êtes nous envoie
ça prouvez le nous ayez du courage soyez
à la hauteur ce soir est très exigeant
avec nous et c'est vrai que je suis
charice c'est pas une parole à mon avis
qu'on doit dire à la légère parce que
faire un journal comme charlie beck on
voit de durand points quand on regarde
l'histoire de journal c'est même si
c'est un journal
facile d'accès il ya de l'humour et la
satire en fait ce dont parle charlie
c'est pas des sujets légers
c'est pas un journal léger charlie même
si la forme peut sembler légère donc
quand on verra mais vraiment les dents
charlie qu'on veut vraiment s'investir à
charlie bell faut assumer aussi
cet engagement est donc on quand on dit
je suis chez rliss ses doigts patins
slogan à la mode c'est c'est pour le
coup c'est un engagement dire je suis
charlie et vous le demandez à ceux qui
vous rejoignent au jeune dessinateur ils
ont 20 ans pour la plupart leur donnant
de rien parce qu'en fait j'ai pas exiger
d'eux je pense que s'ils sont là c'est
que samson le voilà ils le sont enfin
c'est les choses qui n'ont pas besoin
d'être formulée de manière explicite
c'est presque c'est presque comme on
dire des sensations on se comprend on se
comprend voilà c'est un peu comme ça que
que moi j'ai découvert charriant 92
finalement même si on est avec des dix
sénateurs qui étaient plus âgés que nous
finançons là je n'avais pas d'importance
c'est ça qui était vraiment formidable
c'est que on ressentait quasiment les
mêmes choses il n'y avait pas de
différence d'âge
c'est un peu vous avez comme quand une
année scolaire débute on ne connaît pas
bien les gamins de sa classe prudemment
par par attirance ont il ya des
affinités on va vers les copains on se
reconnaît
ouais on se reconnaît il sacré d'une
bande voilà il paraît que vous adorez
les westerns c'est vrai pas plus que ça
ah bon le commentaire non oh non pas
plus que ça non non non j'en regarde un
peu par curiosité parce que cdc presque
des documents les westerns
oui parce que c'est une manière de faire
du cinéma qui a pu disparu et voilà
c'est une vision si du monde un peu
particulière et western absolument j'en
ai trouvé un très étonnant et qui datent
de 56 c'est un film de john ford vous
avec les déficits c'est là c'est la
référence interne la prisonnière du
désert ya john wayne regardez on dirait
qu'il parle de vous cela pourrait
commencer comme un conte
il y avait une fois un homme que l'on
devait craindre et respecter un homme à
la volonté indomptable aux résolutions
violente dans l'histoire est rude et
attachante
voici le roman de sa vie
[Musique]
john wayne dans le rôle de ethan edward
campe un personnage d'une trempe peu
commune
il est par son courage il accomplit des
actes que l'esprit humain à peine à
concevoir mais jamais il ne se prend
pour un martyr jamais non plus il ne se
prend pour un héros te promet qu'en fin
de compte on leur trouvera je te le
promets voici le récit des actions de
cet homme implacable qui ne connaît
point leur peau de cet être tendre et
passionné c'est aussi l'histoire d'un
peuple qui osent s'attaquer à une terre
hostile et les pionniers qui bâtissent
une nouvelle nation jamais il ne se
prend pour un martyr jamais il ne se
prend pour un os
je sais pas je crois pas bon c'est du
cinéma
même si john ford c'est quand même le
haut du panier mais non faut pas non
plus faut pas avancer les choses c'est
bien les filmer la vie c'est pas comme
ça la vie c'est pas comme ça non la vis
et comment s'est passé
c'est plus terre à terre c'est c'est
moins romantique c'est c'est parfois
plus décevant et puis il n'y a pas de
scénario on connaît un film on sait
comment ça commence commença fils
commence à avancer comment ça se termine
donc là c'est je sais pas si on peut
dire que la vie c'est se déroule comme
le scénario d'un film
je pense quand je vois le histoire du
journal tout était imprévisible depuis
25 ans donc des fois je me dis je touche
du bois je me dis qu'est ce qui va
encore nous arriver
voilà donc c'est pas un film peut-être
la meilleure
le meilleur est encore à venir est
toujours à venir ou le pire je sais pas
c'est dire que le pire est passé quand
même non des fois j'en sais rien vous
êtes inquiet je dirais qu'il faut être
vigilant
voilà c'est on peut pas être on ne peut
pas être comment dire après tout ça on
peut pas être léger ou voilà
superficielle quoi mais il faut tenir
compte de ce qui s'est passé
vous dites que vous avez une phrase très
juste très forte
la liberté c'est une décision tout les
jours à chaque instant et si on est dans
le confort on peut pas être libre je
crois que c'est extrêmement vrai mais
alors ça fait pas du tout rêver quoi il
est dit ou six parce que c'est exaltant
c'est c'est d'abord ça vous donne un
objectif
ce que beaucoup de gens n'ont pas dans
la vie quoi faire de sa vie des fois on
se demande ce que les gens ont pour
objectif quand on voit aujourd'hui pas
seulement aujourd'hui mais on a
l'impression qu'on propose aux gens de
quoi
de consommer d'acheter des fondations
que c'est uniquement dans dans la
consommation qu'il se sente vivant alors
que être libre c'est c'est beaucoup plus
difficile parce que vous devez vous
affranchir de beaucoup de choses voilà
c'est plus exigeant mais c'est c'est
comme sortes d'épreuves permanente qui
quand vous y arrive est assez
satisfaisante êtes libre vos j'essaie
d'être de l'être le plus possible avec
mes maigres moyens on n'est jamais
vraiment libre à 100% de fait contre un
plus vous êtes vous vivez sous
surveillance en permanence on peut dire
que votre liberté elle a été à trop fier
ou pas du tout parce qu'elle est dans ma
tête je pense que ce qui est vital c'est
ce qu'on a dans la tête
ouais parce qu'après la liberté d'aller
et de venir bon elle peut-être entravé
mais elle n'est pas non plus totalement
annulée non mais vous adoriez faire des
reportages
c'est vrai vous ne pouvez plus le faire
bah si c'est pas impossible mais c'est
compliqué oui et puis c'est vrai que je
serai quand j'ai fait des reportages
l'étranger le plaisir c'était d'être
seul nulle part oui bout du monde
voilà mais c'est vrai que c'est
difficile d'être seul maintenant est-ce
que vous pensez que l'engagement ça ça
prend ça s'enseigne c'est pas
l'engagement c'est le sens de
l'engagement qu'on doit enseigner c'est
décourage donc non c'est pourquoi on
s'engage on en revient ce que disait
c'est politique
on veut vivre dans quelle société voilà
quand vous posez ça comme question bat
tout le reste vient après vous avez
conscience que vous avez pris une place
très singulière dans nos vies d'ailleurs
vous ne demandiez pas tendre j'imagine
vous avez pris une conscience de ça au
nom du tout je sais pas trop non jeu
un peu étonné des fois de certaines
réactions qui sont comme chaleureuse
mais qui c'est vrai des fois sont un peu
déconcertante mais c'est sait même pas
la question ça aussi c'est agréable ou
pas c'est c'est vrai que c'est presque
un peu gênant de vue comme ça parce que
c'est quoi votre vie vous échappe pour
certains vous êtes un trésor pour
d'autres vous êtes un angle m
pour d'autres vous êtes encore et
toujours une cible c'est quoi c'est ça
c'est votre vie qui vous échappe
dans le fond je pense que ont discuté de
ça justement j'en avais pas très
longtemps quand on fait un dessin quand
on écrit un texte ce qui est plus
intéressant dans le dessein que vous
réalisez ou texte vous écriez c'est ce
que vous ne maîtrisez pas en fait vous
laisser exprimer quelque chose de vous
même que vous ne voyez pas et en fait
c'est ça le plus intéressant donc tu
dirais que dans la vie c'est pareil vous
faites des choses et elles imitent les
votre vie comment dire je peux dire
qu'elle ne vous appartient plus mais
c'est peut-être pas forcément ce à quoi
vous pensez qu'ils intéressent le plus
les gens autour de vous et vous ne le
savez pas mais c'est comme ça et puis
voilà il faut accepter de se dévoiler et
puis d'être que les gens s'emparent de
vous aussi doit à partir du moment où on
fait un métier public
je savais en publiant les premiers
dessins à la grosse bertha 91 que
j'allais être jugé c'est comme si on
entrait sans qu à tous les passants les
gens vont s'approprier vos dessins ils
vont vous juger sévèrement c'est nul
c'est de la merde mais c'est mais si
vous n'acceptez pas sable faut pas faire
un métier où l'on s'exprime en public il
y voilà à ceux qui pensent que vous êtes
austère et exigeant vous dites quoi
qu'ils ont raison j'en sais trop rien
c'est pas moi de répondre à cette
question que vous riez auster exigeant
où il fauté dans ce métier est exigeant
ça c'est sûr et certain les 7 janvier
2015 vous êtes vu mourir vous alliez
mourir et puis ben vous n'êtes pas morts
généralement les gens quand ils
échappent à la mort ils changent quelque
chose dans la vie où eux-mêmes
et vous
qu'est ce qui change je sais pas si je
sais pas si beaucoup de choses ont
changé fondamentalement c'est plus après
une sensation de la vie qui n'est plus à
même puisque avant de vivre ce genre
d'expérience on est un peu inconscient
de de la chance qu'on a d'être vivant en
fête et du luxe qu'on a des vivants
vivants c'est-à-dire de voilà de jouir
de la vie tout vous semble normal tous
nous semble due après ça on en sait
encore plus que rien ne vous et du voile
avec la ville vous n'êtes pas dû la
liberté ne vous ai pas dû et ça vous
rend peut-être encore plus exigeants
c'est ce qu'on disait faut pas gâcher sa
vie à faire n'importe quoi ou des choses
inutiles
même si de temps en temps ça fait du
bien de faire des choses futiles peut
pas remplir sa vie avec des choses
futiles mais il ya une phrase que vous
avez écrite vous dédiez dédié votre
livre et c'est cette phrase va
s'inscrire aux innocents vivant mort au
fond elle sort d'où cette phrase je me
suis dit mais elle sort c'est aux
innocents vivant nord au faou innocent
parce que je pense que
c'était très difficile est difficilement
supportable après le 7 janvier
d'entendre des gens qui nous rend des
responsables de notre sort moi je dis
que voilà on n'est responsable de rien
on est coupable de renault donc il faut
marteler le mot innocent et quand vous
sortez de là et que vous affirmez que
vous êtes innocent vous êtes entourés de
gens morts vivants et puis d'autres qui
qui peut être vont devenir fou ou qui
qui peuvent être menacés par la folie
donc c'est un peu les trois catégories
de devis qui tique qui vous entourent
les vivants les morts est il fou je sais
que vous êtes vivant vous allez perdre
et dernière faut des fois c'est des
questions je me suis posée parce que
[Musique]
parce que c'est c'est difficile de de
reprendre sa place dans le dans la vie
alors qu'autour de vous autant de vies
en interne on enlevait détruites et que
ces vies faisait partie de votre vie en
fait c'est une partie de nos de ma vie
qui a disparu et donc qu'est ce qui vous
reste voilà il faut retrouver un
équilibre
il faut se réinventer un équilibre après
une telle de tels désastres
si c'était à refaire rice bonjour quoi
je ne sais pas je me posais cette
question
c'est à lui qu'il faut pas il faut faire
les choses commente comme on pense qu'on
doit les faire au moment où les faits et
puis voilà le plus honnêtement possible
et en se disant voilà j'assume et
j'assumerai ce que je fais en n'ayant
pas de regret on est en essayant de ne
pas se tromper que ce toujours sans se
tromper mais c'est voilà en essayant de
se tromper le moins possible merci
beaucoup c'est moi merci beaucoup
[Musique]